uh i want to address one of the other
stories that now is going to be a really
big story in the wake of this leaked
supreme court decision that will as far
as we know overturn roe v wade
there immediately were gatherings of
protesters both on the pro-choice and
anti-choice side at the supreme court
and elsewhere as we just saw
protesters on both sides have been
mostly peaceful and anecdotally we have
seen
instances of individuals allegedly
escalating there have been some little
brawls between the two camps and police
have gotten involved at this point i
can't say more than that
uh but there is definitely the potential
that we will see continued or growing
unrest surrounding this decision and the
unrest may come from any side i condemn
violence i'm against violence now that
we've gotten that out of the way
the right is acting as though
it is the pro-choice left that is
uniquely and particularly violent
physically in this political
disagreement and that is a lie the
history of anti-abortion violence
violence is abhorrent and you can easily
google this and find endless examples
cnn has one good article about this
there have been more than 200 bombings
and arson attacks at facilities that
offer abortion services
you could argue that that's terrorism
it's meant to terrorize as a group
those who have or might someday seek
abortion services um
the first reported clinic arson was in
76 just after roe v wade wow what a
shocker there were clinic bombings in 78
and 84. in the 90s it escalated even
more dr david gunn was shot and killed
in pensacola florida by a gunman against
abortion
dr john bayard britain and his security
escort were shot and killed in front of
a pensacola clinic
clinic employees shannon
lowney and leanne nichols were shot and
killed in brookline massachusetts
off-duty police officer robert sanderson
was killed in the bombing of a
birmingham alabama
clinic
a sniper killed dr barnett slepian in
amherst new york and famously famously
an anti-abortion gunman killed 67 year
old george tiller in wichita kansas in
2009 that's a story we covered at the
time our show was on the air
um he was he was killed he was an
abortion clinic director so
these are extraordinarily
violent folks who have been willing to
do all sorts of violence you could argue
it's also violence to show up and
intimidate people going in for medical
services as they've done all over the
country
um and yet you have all of these uh
people on the right acting as though
the right that is against abortion is
completely peaceful
um there is one tweet here
from who is this from this is from
rebecca monsoor who's the senior editor
of breitbart news who said quote the
freakout you are witnessing from the
left is very instructive when roe was
handed down 49 years ago pro-lifers
didn't riot didn't call for the supreme
court to be burned down didn't threaten
the lives of justices and didn't try to
stack the court well they did 200
bombings and attacks of abortion clinics
then uh uh jill phillipovic who's a
writer lawyer and author tweeted
actually since roe was handed down 49
years ago so-called pro-lifers have
committed 11 murders
26 attempted murders 4 kidnappings 42
bombings
667 bomb threats 100 butyric acid
attacks 189 arsons on and on and on
they are violent they are violent don't
let them trick you into thinking that it
is the pro-choice left that is the
violent group now
could either could individuals on either
side anecdotally commit violence in the
next few days sure and i'm against it
and they should be arrested if they
commit a crime or or are believed to
have committed a crime and they should
be uh charged and prosecuted absolutely
both sides don't care who it is but the
historical record
is the violence comes from the
anti-choice side we'll have these clips
and tweets on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show